now the liberal democrats had a pretty
disastrous election in december they
went into the campaign
with 21 mps and emerged with just 11
even their leader jayce winston lost her
seat
so that means there'll be a leadership
election in the summer and one of the
people tipped to run is the party's
education spokesperson leila moran
she's here now in the studio thanks very
much for being with us and before we
talk about
the lib dems i'm just keen to get your
thoughts on coronavirus and
what do you make about the way the uk
government has been responding
well first of all i mean we have to
recognize everyone's really worried
um and not so much for me for example
i'm
young and healthy and i'll be fine but i
worry for my grandparents i worry for
those who are most vulnerable
in the last few days we've been working
together actually with the government to
raise the issues that people are
contacting us about so in particular
statutory sick pay
if you're on zero hours contract in the
gig economy you have to make sure that
you don't have to
make a choice between self-isolating and
eating
i'm also really worried for the homeless
how can you self-isolate if you don't
have a home and the sector's telling me
that they haven't had enough support
from the government
they were a bit slow off the mark but
i'm glad to see they're responding now
okay thank you um now there's of course
a small matter
of the lib dem leadership uh contest uh
you've had uh your name tipped by others
to run are you gonna put your hat in the
ring
yes i will be standing for the
leadership of the liberal democrats
um i believe it's time that we move on
as a party and offer a positive vision
for the country
and i'm the right person to lead that
change so what's the pitch then
so i've been up and down the country
listening to voters
about what went wrong in the election
partly but also asking them questions
about what they think of us i think it's
really important that we listen
and understand where we've been going
wrong what do they think of you
well perhaps it's really interesting so
they
come back and say in the election revoke
was a big mistake because it felt very
top
down and actually cooperation is a key
part of what we believe
as liberal democrats and we need to earn
their trust again
the other thing that worried them was
that we
were saying that we were going to be the
party of the next government when in
fact
that wasn't the case and we lost their
trust again
over that so then i asked them well what
do you think we stand for
and that's the bit that's really
worrying because they then say well
nine times out of ten we don't know and
the key question we have to answer now
is what are we
for that's the question that is missing
from the eyes of the voters so
i then asked well what would turn you
what would bring you to us
and they're really clear actually it's
quite interesting up and down the
country leaves areas remain areas rural
urban
it's about equality of opportunity in
particular they mention education which
of course was the reason i went in
to politics they mention the climate
crisis and the fact that
all political parties need to urgently
tackle that and they also want a less
tribal politics a kinder gentler
politics where we are working together
as politicians on the things that matter
to them
and aren't so focused on us okay um i
just want to unpick a couple of things
that you were
saying there about the reasons that
people turned away from you at the last
election because actually
you know i'm sure you'll admit it was a
pretty uh disappointing
result should we say for the lib dems
and you were saying then that
you're saying that the livedones could
be a party of part of government was a
mistake and but then during the campaign
i interviewed
you in the studio and asked if you
thought joe swinson could be prime
minister and
and you said this and i think that she
could i do
at other elections i would have held
back from that but given the volatility
of politics right now it's entirely
possible
i mean so the timing of that was in
november
and at that time we were in an
unprecedented situation where you had a
four-way split
among the parties and we were you know
vying for space with both the brexit
party and the tories the thing that
changed and that
this was the moment and people are very
clear about this this was the moment
where we lost the credibility
when the brexit party stood down in
favor of the conservatives and it became
very clear that in
the first past the post system that
couldn't happen we continued
to say that even in november we should
have something j swinson was going to be
prime minister or could be prime
minister's a bit of a stretch
well i think i said that on this program
and i said very much that it was a
stretch target but it was possible at
that time and i think it was absolutely
right to be ambitious for the party and
i continue to be ambitious for the party
but one of the big things that is very
clear is under the first past the post
system
for the third party to then pull through
that's very difficult and electoral
reform
is one of the things that i think we
need to keep pushing i'm very heartened
by the fact that
labour party uh leadership candidates
have been starting to talk about this i
do hope that this might be the moment
that we achieve electoral reform in this
country and the other
criticism you made of the campaign was
the strategy of revoke this idea that
if the lib dems were in government they
would cancel article 15 and cancel
brexit all together
um did you speak up against the policy
did you vote against it in libdem
conference then i did not
no and actually interestingly i've been
reflecting on how we make decisions in
the party
in the rooms where these decisions were
being discussed and i do not absolve my
self-responsibility at all from this
but there weren't enough dissenting
voices and it became very clear that we
were
you know surrounded by remain seats
people who had
campaigned ardently for that remained
position and to move away from the
people's votes which i think would have
worked in many parts of the country
was partly led by a lack of diversity of
voices in that room so you should have
perhaps spoken up more you should have
been one of those dissenting voices
yourself
at the time i was focused on my seat um
my very marginal seat
i don't anymore i've increased my
majority massively and it would have
worked for me
but what was really clear is that you
know voices from the southwest former
heartlands voices from
yorkshire voices from elsewhere in the
country weren't in that room and i do
think we need to look very deeply at how
we make
big strategic decisions in the party and
as leader i do think that that is
something that would have to change
um some people as well you when you're
talking about
not knowing what their livedones are for
and some people still feel that going
into coalition with the conservatives
was
a mistake i'm interested to know your
view on that should the lib dems be
owning
the achievements that they made in
coalition or is that a time that they
should be distancing themselves from
so when i discuss this with people it
does come up and it's disappointing that
it comes up
because it feels like it was a long time
ago but i think it's what coalition did
was it
eroded trust in the party but i don't
just
look at coalition as the problem i
actually also look at the last five
years
and the fact that since then since we
haven't been in government we haven't
been able to
positively put forward what we are for
you know talking about public services
education the nhs these are the things
that people want us to talk about
if the um coalition is something that
still comes up would it be a mistake for
the party to
elect a leader who was perhaps a
minister in the coalition it will be up
to the party to decide who they are
going to elect but my pitch
is very much about what's your personal
view on i it will be up to the party to
decide but what's very clear for voters
is it still does come up
and if we can present a party that has
moved on that's moved on afresh
has the vision has the policies that
speak to people for them and their
families then i do think that that will
win us success again
talk about moving on um should the lib
dems be the party of rejoining
the eu so my position on this is that
i will never stop fighting for those
internationalist values cooperations are
big parts
not just nationally but internationally
and i think one of the things i regret
is whilst people knew we were
against brexit we never explained why
and it's because we want to work with
others
but we also have to accept where we are
i think the biggest
worry i have right now is in june
we have a flash point which is the
government has said they will walk away
if they don't get a deal that's no deal
that's
no one wants no deal except possibly
some very uh
ardent anti-europeans in the
conservative party this is not the right
thing for the country that's what we
need to focus on now
and if there is a way to leave that door
open so that one day
with public consent we go back i would
be first in line
uh very quickly because we haven't got
much time if you do
become leader of the liberal democrats
which are the three contenders for the
labour leadership would you most fear
well actually i think there's an
opportunity now to be working with other
parties not just labour
okay who do you most like to work with
in our phrasing well it's it's not up to
me
it's not up to me i i honestly think
that we could work with
all of them and on particularly
electoral reform i'm so pleased that all
of them have said that there is
something they could work with us on
that okay
layla moran thank you very much uh
announcing uh your bid
to be the next lib dem leader on the
show much appreciated thank you